testing the D behind the net is Evangelista Luke
Evangelista to forsberg forsberg shoots and a save
made by the Smith touched up and Saturday night
against Carolina in Washington here's Gus nikist
across the line for Nashville forsberg will peel
it back for Yosi he shoots save made by the Smith
with the blocker and uh that's tough that's that's
that's terrible so here's a fouron four situation
Alex Kier turning the corner getting the shot
on to Smith pad save it ends up on the stick
of Miller Good crossy Feet TN Hugh orchestrating
shot from straight on good save by Soros through
the track qun Hughes chases along the line he's
so good as a skater he almost tries to lure you
in side of the net now they probe 28 seconds
to go inching closer Pon tries to jam it it
it's loose on the backside and the net knocked
off watch this he's looking pass right now he
wants to think everybody back he sees some space
he's trying to get Saros to open up a little bit
of a burst there to get him to open up far post
and Saros just keeps his structure nothing in the
middle and then pushes out to the right look
at that he's just all over it 3.75 per game
JT Miller attacks mcdunn clipped with a backand
by hoglander fed to an open man saved by sorrow
he challenge besser but Loose along the board
fighting for it and coming up with it is siss
siss has had some big goals of late here's a
shot by Shen got through Smith didn't see it
to the last instant he skated hard the whole time
in the corner it goes Barry looking for it a nice
flip with the one hand to chip it ahead now Shin
goes cross ice good pass to Cole Smith makes the
Stop and turn well defended by Vancouver now
up the wing pon pon gets in shoots he scores
that's an elite shooter right there Elias Pon a
great oneman show it's going to be on his backand
right here Barry turns around he's going to try
to push him the outside he gets caught right
there and then look at that he just puts it it's
right in the middle of his stance no Telegraph
he's not even looking at the net his head's down
he knows exactly where he's shooting and he just
flexes that stick right over the pad and he
was he was on the outside I mean that that's
just a that's a shot that's just a Superstars
can make the those kind of shots Vancouver has
had everything go in all year long five oh this
one kicked out in front and a second goal a lucky
bounce and kneels Oman Johnny on the spot gets
his first goal of the year and then again right
here watch this Puck it's in the corner Oman gets
a a bounce right here it's going to go right out
to him there's battles we can't see where the
puck is right here funny bounce off the side
of the net I think and then Oman beats Saros in
the same spot from a different angle oh my Goda
challenging Lozan saying hey we got to answer for
that meanwhile it's Pino getting all the way in
on the other side here goes McCarron there's a
breakway right here B thomasino it just misses
he long stretch pass got a man open here comes
forsberg fires one and a save is made forsberg
trying to get his own rebound good defense
around the boards Center in in front and a great
sprawling save on Pon out of nowhere Pon appeared
out of the trees Evangelista turn towards in that
shoots trying to tip it his glass charging it is
Smith couldn't quite get there let on back to the
net back down in front rebound Smith here in front
on to Smith and he gets ends up on his heaster
here battling but that was a big save by Casey to
Smith berett always thinking about these things
here's a breaka away for nwit he's in save made
maybe off the mask of Casey Des Smith Nashville
had a re basic the Smith has been outstanding as
the backup the play by perryer took his man out
matfield breaks out if they hurry they've got a
four on three they come across the line it is loan
he well who are you going to call lately if
you need a big goal against the hurricanes in
Carolina it was Jeremy lazon that got the boys
back in the hockey game and here tonight lazon
steps in but watch that pass from Luke Evangelista
pretty boy venzo that's the beauty of the second
period if you can ice tilt it it really can work
in your favor you got to have good changes or guys
have done a good job with that so far we got to
maintain our Motion in the ozone and keep them
away from those long stretch plays that they're
so good at and we should be okay but uh we got
a long ways to go left in this game and they're
one turnover away from making you pay so we got
to be tight all right thanks coach you B guys and
unfortunately Vancouver gets the goal back set
play off the faceof ma yeah exactly they they win
it back and it's just coming to the net they're
going to the net front and H glander gets on that
side right here good battle I'll tell you what you
talk about they have that Superstar power Quin
Hugh is one of the best players in the National
Hockey League but he's partnered up with Roni and
this is a guy that's been a good solid player for
a lot of years but really put him on on this map
as a a different kind of player here this year in
Vancouver shot from the [__] behind SOS and it
goes in it leaked just behind sorrow in the crease
and trickled across the line if it trickled
behind Soros here the puck just they're just
putting things to the net they're just throwing it
to that look at that just a quick shot yeah it was
and then Kier again right here he's battling
with sud sud gets his stick loose and then
just tucks it in behind Soros carry in a good
position it was they had that puck good defense
there by Hughes glass trying to keep the play a
wide and Hughes moves it ahead Hughes coming in
Hughes is in and makes the save Soros shout out
of a cannon right here yeah we're going to call
this an Nissan defensive stop as you said Willie
this goes in it's game over look at the back check
right here at sorrow is Quinn Hughes one of the
hottest best defenseman in the National Hockey
League 15 seconds to go Miller stretching save
rebound on second save by Soros tip the head
siss racing after it Hughes trying to hold him
off siss takes it and Hughes able to hang in
there and weather the storm what a save on
heroni right in the slot right in the slot
that was was a great rebound Deddy pluger he
scores right after the power play expires oh
a dagger by the Canucks Nashville got a big
kill and then Bluer came over the boards and
gets a big timely goal penalty Saros a couple of
huge saves but watch this look at this job here
Bluer is going to get up from the outside and
then look at the quick hands and he goes short
side there's no room there Saros was actually
leaning a bit he see him right there he faded
a bit to the right that was very similar they
do it here pppi who weekly was a predator when
Peter lavet was the coach years ago not for
very long and now here's nqu shoot he hits
the pose great here coming off they had it
bench slam that went under that was a great
shot coming into it two on one mckv looking
with Pon shoots save ba by lanin it a good one
F pressured fugh can't escape they overwhelm him
thomasino stopped tried to go five hole and this
team as a whole has done a pretty good job of
recovering from a night that doesn't go their
way I'm thinking about the game in Toronto I'm
thinking about that Minnesota game that was 6
to1 they boun back quickly in those cases that
there's a go by Cody glass so Cody glass gets
his first goal of the year and hopefully that
will spark him to better things and that's an
important goal for him he's trying to get his
game going it's 5-1 the game's over but as a
player when you get that goal like this nice
play here part Cole Smith doing the work in
the corner to get that puck turned over
that's a big goal for glass so we'll see
if there's a carry over as the final horn will
sound so the Canucks have successfully come in